whatever you think of the new Netflix
adaptation of One Piece Oda the creator
of One Piece was a part of it and we're
told that everything went through Oda
and there were even reshoots when Oda
requested them and considering that
after all these years and almost 1 100
chapters in the manga Oda got a chance
to in a sense redo the beginning of the
series in light of what he knows now
this new beginning is different and
reveals the one-piece ending in a way
that the original beginning never did
and never could so make sure to stay
tuned for that see on the pirate king
within and smash that like button if you
want to see more one piece videos like
this one especially about the live
Netflix adaptation let me know in the
comments too make this the video you
joined the not come up by subscribing
and helping us reach our dream of 2
million subscribers on YouTube Every
subscription counts thank you and now
without further Ado let's jump into the
spoilers and all so to see the important
differences in the new beginning of one
piece or what we could call the romance
Dawn portion of the series we first got
a look at the way Oda did it originally
so in the manga when the mountain
Bandits come into the bar Luffy finds
himself self eating his devil fruit
before that he was eating some bread so
it makes it seem like the fruit really
wasn't that big of a deal to the red
hair Pirates since they weren't really
taking care of it that well yes they
were distracted but it was ultimately
unwatched and available for someone like
Luffy to eat eventually Shanks freaks
out when he sees that Luffy's stretchy
lucky Roo says it's not here the gum gum
fruit we took from that enemy ship shank
says that was the gum gum fruit the
fruit of the devil it's one of the
secret treasures of the sea if you eat
it your entire body becomes like rubber
and you will never be able to swim for
the rest of your life so yeah Shanks
makes it seem like a big deal but it
seems like he would have reacted the
same way if it was any devil fruit it's
also hard to know how much of his
concern is for the fruit and how much is
for Luffy who will never be able to swim
for the rest of his life so Oda wrote
this beginning way back when in 1997.
now some people might think Oda knew
everything that would come next for the
next two and a half decades and Beyond
but that's just unrealistic what's more
likely is that Oda probably had add some
bigger ideas in his mind but mostly let
his story unfold and we know he's not a
superhuman Master planner because he
repeatedly underestimates how long it
would take to end one piece but
significantly the Netflix adaptation
beginning as we're going to get into
feels like it knows exactly what's
coming after all Oda has already written
almost 1 100 chapters and has a better
handle on the ending than in 1997 and
the Netflix show makes changes
accordingly but to understand what I
mean we must get into Luffy's devil
fruit the gum gum fruit which as we
discovered relatively recently isn't the
gungun fruit at all but actually the
mythical Zone sun god Nica fruit so gear
5 is teased at the end of chapter 1043
where we see a Luffy that should be out
of commission smile and on top of that
it looks like his face is melting we're
even told joyboy has returned adding
even more significance to this Awakening
and fruit during chapter 1044 we learn
more thank you to the elders for sharing
some light on the sun god at marijuana
it's asked and I quote so we've lost an
elite agent and made kaido Angry what
was the point end quote and then Elder
Saturn the one who is currently coming
with kizaru to attack Egghead says what
if I told you that there was a potential
future that would make us a beg for this
outcome it is always better to eliminate
dangerous variables then another Elder
says in every era the world government
has attempted to recover the gum gum
fruit and not once has it ever succeeded
for 800 years it is as though the devil
fruit is trying to escape our grasp and
it very well might be Zone fruits
contain a will of their own and this
particular fruit has the name of a God
the other name of the gum gum fruit is
the Zone type human human fruit mythical
type model Nika end quote so when this
came out it was definitely a lot to
unwrap obviously the big reveal that the
gum gum fruit is not a paramecia but
actually a mythical zone is huge in and
of itself then there's the fact that
zones have a will of their own they can
even invade the world government we then
see a silhouette of Luffy's new form in
the sky as the elders continue to
explain possess a body with the
properties of rubber and fighting in
whatever way he fancies bringing smiles
to the faces of the people the warrior
of Liberation also known as Nika the sun
god Awakening brings his rubber body
greater physical strength and freedom it
is said that in all the world there is
no power more ridiculous end quote so we
got even more to unpack there the fruit
is associated with the body possessing
the properties of rubber which explains
why the government wanted to hide the
truth and decided to do it by lying and
saying it's just a rubber paramecia
fruit this is the only instance of name
changing that we know of in the series
next we're told importantly that the
mythical zone is a warrior of Liberation
makes sense for someone like Luffy who
loves freedom and ends up freeing people
wherever he goes and like it says here
he also puts smiles on people's faces
we're informed that Luffy's body will
get power and freedom boosts AKA his
fists will pack more punch and his body
will be to put it mildly impossibly
flexible and adaptable but more
importantly we're told that it is the
most ridiculous power in the world and
that it can let the fighter fight in
whatever way he fancies that pretty much
means Luffy can do anything even the
impossible he's only limited by his
imagination if we take it seriously back
to awaken Luffy and he says ooh I can do
everything I wanted to do I think I can
fight a bit longer my heartbeat sounds
so funny this is the Pinnacle of what I
can do this is gear 5 end quote he then
uses this old but newly awakened fruit
to beat Yoko kaido the so-called
strongest creature which pretty much
makes the sun god the new strongest
creature title holder now you can say
that Oda was aware that he'd do this
back in chapter one and yeah he probably
was aware of some of it but there is a
lot of ambiguity in the first chapter
yeah Shanks does have the fruit and he
does have an over-the-top reaction when
Luffy eats it but it could be just
because all devil fruits are valuable
and he worries about what it means for
Luffy he sacrifices his arm for Luffy
who ate the most ridiculous of devil
fruit powers and the one associated with
joy boy and most likely the liberation
of the world but it could also be
because because Shanks just wanted to
save his friend we don't really see when
Luffy grabbed for the fruit in the chest
so we don't really know how it happened
it could have just been open near him
and he could have just been like let's
try some of that while I'm eating
already so not saying the first chapter
doesn't allow for the sun god Nika
reveal eventually just saying that it
could allow for it but it doesn't really
have to the Netflix adaptation is a
different story though Oda now with over
two and a half Decades of hindsight
knows 100 percent the significance of
this fruit the fact that it's arguably
the most significant of all fruits and
the Netflix adaptation acts accordingly
lucky Roo is carrying the box with the
fruit in it with other box on the ship
and Shanks takes it and says easy with
this route it's worth more than the rest
of the loot put together here we have
the proper emphasis and Care we'd expect
from our Shanks knowing the truth about
this fruit and considering Shanks is
usually a Carefree guy him saying
something like this is a big deal in
this version the fruit isn't casually
unwatched at a bar but carefully stowed
away where it should be the safest yet
Luffy still wanders in and immediately
pinpoints onto it he takes that specific
box rather than anything else around
he's not even eating mind you he opens
the box and sees the fruit inside the
cinematography makes it clear that the
fruit is calling out to him in some way
heavily foreshadowing the fact that zone
fruits have Wills they can exercise
something that Oda maybe didn't even
know when he wrote chapter one and so it
wasn't really emphasized and so here
rather than casually grabbing a nearby
fruit while he's eating Luffy pinpoints
a well stowed away box where the fruit
is and decides to try eating it and
finishes it despite the fact that it
doesn't look like he's enjoying it at
all rather than freaking out here in his
usual comedic way shank says Luffy what
have you done in a serious way making it
feel like less Shanks being Shanks and
more like oh snap this fruit is
important enough to make Shanks get
serious the quote what have you done
definitely adds a lot of weight to
Luffy's action of eating the fruit so
all these changes in the adaptation
spoil one of the endings namely that the
gum gum fruit is not just any devil
fruit but the most important sun god
Nika devil fruit that's associated with
joy boy and Liberation Shanks treated it
with more care and significance and it
called out more clearly to Luffy
emphasizing that it is a Zone with a
will of its own while in the manga it
could have been any nearby devil fruit
that Luffy could have happened to reach
out and eat while he was already eating
other things later on Luffy in the
adaptation emphasizes again its future
significance by saying these devil fruit
powers are gonna make me the greatest
pirate ever and and I quote all I know
is that the gum gum fruit is worth more
than all of shanks's treasure and I ate
it so that makes me worth more end quote
and let's just say someone as big as
Shanks probably has a lot of treasure
even at this point in the story so
that's saying a lot it's pretty much
another way of saying it's worth Beyond
monetary value and after that it makes
sense why Shanks would leave the straw
hat with Luffy since the straw hat is
associated with the will of Roger and
Shanks and joy boy since it's likely
that like Roger Shanks hopes that joyboy
will return to liberate the world and
this fruit is associated with that
future it makes sense he'd want Luffy to
have that hat since the fruit already
picked him the fact that he was grave
when he said Luffy what have you done
may also mean that chase is aware Luffy
will have to go through a lot and
perhaps even death if he is to fulfill
the prophecy as the New Joy boy he might
not like putting that pressure and
suffering on his young friend at this
point but it's over now and now all he
can do is place his hope in him and he
doesn't even hesitate to sacrifice his
arm for Luffy and the new era and
speaking of the Armed sacrifice while
there are very important differences and
that is very telling as well in the
manga shakes is in the water and saves
Wolfie last minute so maybe he like used
insane super speed to just barely save
Luffy in time and so wasn't able to use
Conker's hockey in time to scare off the
Seabees but once again there is less
ambiguity in the Netflix adaptation here
in the Netflix adaptation although they
emphasize is conquerors hockey when he
asked the Seabees to leave they make it
clear that Shanks willingly sacrifices
his arm in front of Luffy like he had
the time and luxury of coming over on a
boat saw the Sea Beast coming and the
Sea Beast even hesitated for a bit and
just looked at them before attacking and
snapping off his arm it's just
impossible to argue here that he didn't
have time to use conquerors hockey so
it's clear he wanted Luffy to see him
lose the arm and to see how dangerous
the sea is probably so he wouldn't cut
corners and be over eager thus giving
him a better chance of survival in the
long run and thus better ensuring the
chance of Luffy carrying out the joy boy
liberating the world prophecy Luffy does
respond accordingly and says in the
adaptation that Shanks was right for not
letting him join the crew since he's not
ready it does a good job of showing how
Luffy was over eager thinking he could
rush in and now he knows how dangerous
the sea is and he gives himself 10 years
to train and get ready who knows if he
didn't give himself those 10 years
because of shanks's arm he may never
have survived this long but since he did
it seems clear now that Luffy wolf of
fill his dreams as he says of finding
the one piece and being pirate king
using his sun god fruit to become the
strongest and shanks's likely hope for
him of liberating the world which is
tied to Joy boy and the prophecy and so
for all the faults you can find in the
series from how much takes place in the
dark to fan favorite moments and
characters left out there are strengths
like an ability to redo Key Parts with
hindsight and although some old missions
and changes in the series did bother me
I still felt the exciting Spirit of One
Piece while watching this show and I
look forward to season two so I'd say
that it does succeed as an adaptation
even though I would never say it
replaces the original but let me know
your thoughts in the comments right now
and if you like mythical Zone fruits
like Luffy's and want to learn more
about them you won't want to miss my all
mythical zones and their powers
explained video link on screen right now
smash that like button help us achieve
our dream of getting to 2 million
subscribers and I'll see you next time